so um good morning everybody welcome to
the workshop of geometric complexity
theory
it's my pleasure to introduce aviva song
from his beautiful advanced study i
think he doesn't need any production
he's so well known
he will speak about matrix rank
applications all the problems
these stages
uh
so i realized after uh
listening to talks here for two days
that this talk is going to be
quite a bit different than
uh many of the talks you heard it's uh
first of all
it's not so directly connected to
uh
the the topic discussed here gct
although some of the
some of the
things i've mentioned are definitely
related it's more uh
just taking advantage of the fact that
there are so many algebraic and
algebraic theometers in the audience
and
that i have so much so many problems
uh
that that are on the border of algebra
and combinatorics that are some or most
are motivated by computational
complexity that you know it's an
opportunity maybe you can help us
uh solve some of them uh they all
uh all these problems so this talk
another difference would be that it will
have about uh
seven or eight topics so
you know i'll switch context many times
uh the common theme will be rank and it
will be about
this will be the theme and then we'll
see lots of variations on ranking
questions about these
variations
so
you know if you lose me on one
you can wake up for the other and it's a
brand new
uh
right so
let me start
so i'll start
the basic
notion of matrix rank
which needs no introduction
so i'll have a
field and for most problems are
mentioned the field wouldn't matter i
mean it's the open problems are open for
any field you know maybe you can
do it for some
and we'll work with the n by n matrices
so
over this field and uh
the type of you know for each topic you
know it will be more or less the same
structure i'll tell you a measure like
rank and i'll tell you that uh well
let's let's say here uh if we take a
matrix here matrix a
then we know that i mean it's trivial
but let me just say it for most
for most such a the rank of a
is bigger than n over time
bigger i will be sloppy with constant
they will not matter much
so
one type of fact will be that
most objects have
high complexity measure and then the
task the the really difficult problem
which was mentioned here many times this
derandomization problem
is to find
to exhibit
an explicit
a
with with high complexity measure
in this case rank well this is a trivial
problem we know many pro for example if
i take
the identity matrix
so that you know in this particular case
it's easy as you'll see in all the other
cases it's not easy
but this is the type of
you know this would be the structure and
when i say exhibit and explicit so we
discussed
many arguments here about the notion of
explicit first of all i don't think that
the uh that
there's such a large difference between
mathematical explicitness and
computational explicitness uh
because
most things you come up with that you
think are explicit will probably satisfy
both the mathematicians and the computer
scientists what complexity theory allows
you to do is to give a formal definition
of what explicit is what explicit is
why is this an answer an explicit answer
because really the sequence i n you know
all these matrices uh you know they have
for n
or n in n
they have uh they all have one can so
it's a sequence that's easily generated
but what does it mean or explicit what
does that mean means that
you know in general what we would like
to do is to have
an algorithm that runs in polynomial
time in n
that would generate a sub n in this
sequence
that's what explicit would mean formally
so for example is clearly
uh easy we don't necessarily need that
the sequence will have you know exists
for all integers for example
uh a matrix that will come up a lot is
what's called the adam
or sylvester matrix
uh it's just an orthogonal plus minus
one matrix
okay so one plus minus one matrix we
don't have it exactly for all integers
we know many integers for which it
exists for example
yeah for example yeah
but anyway we know it's very easy to
generate such matrices let's say
h n where n is the power of two
right this is basically the fourier
transform matrix of uh df2 to the m the
df2 to the k so
this will be good enough
that's explicit okay so let me go to the
first uh and please stop me with
questions if anything
so let's go to the first non-trivial uh
complexity measure and this is the
the topic is made with rigidity
i think you'll see that many of these
problems are motivated from
many different fields in complexity
theory and theoretical computer science
so somehow lots of things boil down to
rank related issues
so i'll motivate i'll tell you where
these problems are coming from in our
cases so what's matrix rigidity
um
say that the matrix a
is rs rigid
first in words
this is is rigid if not only it has iran
but also all all its neighbors in the
hammock distance
have high rank if you change few of the
entries it remains high ranked no matter
how you change these entries so
if for every b
so that uh
b minus a in the hamming distance
is of course s so this means just that
uh
we have bij different than aij
oh
for at most s
uh so if you change some of the answers
as of the entries
uh the rank of b is still
at least r
and it's really easy to see over any
field
sometimes the world most has to be
clarified when you work over i don't
know
infinite fields but basically
uh
most most a
are very rigid
even if you change
like 10 of the entries you cannot reduce
the rank
below linear
it's a simple counting argument or
dimensional argument
so most areas are rigid
um
about getting explicit examples like
this where the best we can do
uh so explicitly if we want to explicit
what we do know is that for example the
matrix h this h sub n the hadamard
master says
there are non trivial bounds i mean they
are not difficult but all
and squared overall
it is more or less
the best we can do so notice that here
the product of r and s is cubic
and here the products of r s is
quadratic and what we really want is
explicit examples that beat this
quadratic bound it would be
so an open problem is is a
explicit a's were which are rs rigid
rs
let's say
bigger than n to the two plus epsilon
uh
it's a great challenge people worked on
it
for decades and let me tell you why they
work on it for decades
uh different
type of parameters here will imply
different things the this problem was
introduced the rigidity notion was
introduced by valiant
so that
if you can get
something like
n over 10
into the one plus epsilon so one example
of this trade-off
um
rigid makes explicit rigid matrices this
implies i'm not going to specify but it
implies some circuit lower bounds
coolant circuit lower bounce this will
be a major we don't know how to do this
kind of thing
and rasbo showed in a different regime
so the same implications for circum
complexity there is an implication to
communication complexity if you can get
some like n to the epsilon
here n squared over 10. so i you change
10 and 10 percent of the entries and all
you want is that the rank doesn't drop
below into the episode it looks like
it's
trivial
we don't know how to do this
and this will imply
uh certain communication complexity
lower bounds for those who know
doesn't matter what they are
but anyway it will be
important it's a big open problem and we
don't know how to solve it so that's the
motivation
yes i said it doesn't matter it doesn't
matter there is some communication fear
this
yeah no i mean i can't do that letter p
ph
and this is p space it's just uh
complexity classes but not in the
boolean
functions but for communication
complexity we'll separate two complexity
classes that we don't know how to
support like p versus np in the
communication
okay
questions about this
yeah so notice what i meant explicit
that this is a very good question
you want a polynomial time argument
right
square roots of pranks not squares or
points uh
you want the polynomial time algorithm
that will write down this method in
particular the output should be matrix
of integers of let's say polynomial bit
length right
well whatever an algorithm can write it
can write bits you know it takes
so i don't allow you to cheat and put
here you know uh transcendental numbers
or square roots of clients which you
need really you know
for the result you need infinite
precision stuff like that yeah
yeah
i think that volume season
means for the polynomial time yeah yeah
if you have if you have if you can
generate such matrices in polynomial
time then you find an explicit a problem
in p in fact you will have a problem in
p which has a circuit sort of
superlinear
it's not quite i'm not specifying but
non-trivial something we cannot do it
yeah so sorry
so what if it was just sort of
some linear combination of primes or
polynomials and primes it's not explicit
yeah sure i mean as long as there's an
algorithm that writes them down of
course it is yeah yeah you can write
clients you can
you can really think a computer
but but in fact but joseph but but let
me go back but let me go back to what i
said in the beginning it's also okay if
you you know just describe to me uh
something with roots of unity is like
the fourier transform matrix uh
over you know
you know other groups something that you
can define for me for all n
right
well i'll be happy
but you do want it to have something
square with some primes
yeah okay yeah yeah okay yeah infinite
precision
it's a great discussion actually about
explicit but you know forget the
definition give me a sequence of
matrices
and then we'll argue and you know it
claims that square root of primes i'll
tell you that's not a kosher because
it's uh it's infinite possible
random matrices
i mean we know that makes a random
matrices count they are fine i don't
want randomly i want you to
deterministically generate this this is
the problem the whole problem like i
said is the randomization problem we
would know
that most that random matrices are good
we would know that in all these cases
and we would not know
okay
so for example by the way let me just uh
tell you one of my favorite
this is something that was invented by
howard karloff the problem of you have a
space and most objects of the space have
a property
right this is a situation here and you
want to exhibit one
this is the problem of finding hay in a
haystack turns out that finding hay in
haystacks is not an easy problem i mean
there are many examples where it's
really different
it's proving that
you took hay
sometimes it's hard to yeah certified
it's hard to prove that yeah
yeah that's why okay well even even in
many cases i mean so in algebraic
geometry there's a basic option called
modular space of curves and you can talk
about curves and special properties of
general occurs
general curves are dense and nobody
knows how to write one down once you get
past history
of this for a long time
so
mathematics is full of examples like
this and this talk is just about
examples that have to do with the
variations alright so
uh okay
good let me switch to a different
example i want to talk about approximate
rank you'll see that
various twists
approximate rank and here i need the
field to be to have some uh distance
matrix on a metric on it so it can be r
or c
anyway uh so what what
the epsilon rank of a matrix
i mean it's very similar to rigidity you
are allowed to perturb the matrix but
now you are allowed to perturb it in the
only in the
small perturbation at infinity matrix d
not infinity this
so the minimum rank
the length of b
is that
b minus a negative infinity
yeah this is a
this is a friendlier problem much
friendlier than the
uh
revisited problem
excuse me
but yeah you can normalize you you can
yeah you can you can think of a as a
let's let's say that it's a plus minus
one
okay
uh
so of course i mean it's really easy to
see that most a
i mean if epsilon is small let's say
absolutely
uh most a
um
like epsilon of a
now
this is easy and it turns out that here
exhibiting a particular uh
you know high complexity a is not very
difficult our friend the demand matrix
is like that so it turns out that also
most of them
yeah but i as i said i don't want to go
i don't want to go into this this is
true i want to be sloppy in many cases
there are sharper estimates
in almost all of them
for that amount matrix it turns out that
you can very easily prove it's just an
eigenvalue calculation
it's very close to end
so it's really easy to to prove the
bound but sometimes that's not the
interesting example so let me ask you
instead of the hadamard matrix what do
you think is the rank
the epsilon rank
of the identity matrix
you're allowed to perturb the entries up
to epsilon and you want to reduce the
rank as much as possible
how far can you reduce
it's an easy result
that's not that's very small
and this is the
one way to think about it and one
motivation to study this epsilon rank of
the identity matrix is this a
good birthday shop of bound encoding
theo
and this is the motivation for studying
it and here the question is okay this
how to this easy to prove by a
probabilistic argument and the main
question here
is
make this upper bound explicit
so generate so we know that such
matrices exist low rank matrices which
epsilon approximate the identity we know
they exist
and this is also johnson linda's 12th
dimensional reduction so it comes from
so here explicit is is this construction
of epsilon approximation is is a basic
is a fundamental problem in coding
theory it's about length
and another fundamental question in
coding theory is what's the right answer
that's just an upper bound
is a beautiful law bound by noga alone
which is almost tied logan
or epsilon squared block one over
epsilon
and distinguishing the two is about the
the most basic question encoding theory
is the rate versus distance
so
we don't know
yeah so we know things about you know
coding theory and in jail and i mean
what what are the uses these
what are the explicit upper bounds so
for example if you put here a square log
n squared over epsilon square this we
can do explicitly or if you do log n
over epsilon cube this we can do
explicitly there are
yeah but we are far from
yeah it's very basic
uh okay
let me switch again and now i want to
talk about sign rank
another another basic uh
problem
it comes from
both the computational learning theory
and communication complexity and there
are other motivations i'm not going to
get into them but let me
define it here we again we will look at
matrices that are just plus minus 1
matrices
and we need to be over the reals
because we need science
real estate doesn't matter
uh
okay so what's the what's the problem
here what's the sign rank
uh rank of a matrix a
it's the smallest link
you can
have of a matrix that have the same
signs in every entry like a so a is a
sine matrix you can change the numbers
any way you like maintaining the sign
and
the question how low can you get so the
minimum rank
the
vij
times aij
okay so
you know if you've never seen it looks
real but actually it's important
uh and and here also it's uh it's true
for most a
the the sign length
is
easily now
close to end
not
blah blah i'll available
all of the others are really easy to
prove this is not easy or it's rather
easy once you know some real algebraic
geometry it uses the most in terms of
the number ordinance or something no i
said the most
in most days of certain areas
yeah yeah fine yeah
and uh it uses the
warren theorem
basically the bound on on connect
components that
hypersurfaces can device can cut up
space too
many if you know this basic result then
it is it and you are looking for
explicit examples
and
you know we don't know anything linear
i'll tell you the best we know this is a
result of foster
and he proved that the sign length
the program matrix you see there is only
one example
the most problem
the biggest problem with explicit
examples is that we know very few
families of matrices of objects
either those or random
ah so this at least
well then
actually prove the
better
more general com
the final rank of any matrix a
any sign matrix we say
is at least
n over the spectral norm
and that of course follows
and the
basic open problem here is find
lenovo
electricity
for sign language
it would be extremely interesting for
for these applications i mentioned
okay let me see how i'm doing
uh
let me tell you about one more
maybe i'll get to it at the end if i
have time so let me just mention another
thing i want to talk about is rather
than having rather rather than looking
at the rank of matrices with the same
pattern of sign as a as a given matrix
you can ask about the same patterns of
zeros versus non-zeros this you can do
for any field
and it's really interesting and so let's
do rigidity but maybe i'll
i'll do it at the end or
if you ask me
are there any known relationships
between these questions
yeah so here is
between these and things like i don't
know other standard things in
communication
yeah yeah so they are
some of them are more on the wishful
thinking side than on the
i mean they are related so like i said
in the applications you can see where
they are related to you know modern
complexity in learning theories uh
is uh related to this
between these three there is no
different explanation but if we were
going to talk about the
this zero non-zero pattern instead of
sign patterns there at least in my mind
uh there's a project we've been pursuing
with the fda which we saw
uh
how it might
give explicit
so let me say let me just state a
theorem i will not motivate it but just
so which related to this
uh
that has to do with the zero and zero
and but i'll just make it explicit
and
so there are connections and uh there
are connections to other things like
ramsey and extractors and yeah which i'm
not
which i'm not getting into let me just
saw on this uh
zero
non-zero length
so
it turns out that
everybody here's another explicit
example that
people like of matrices is the
projective plane matrix so if this is n
uh it's a projective plane
strain matrix
the projective plane makes sense i have
no it's an incidence uh
it's the incidence uh matrix of lines
versus points in the projective plane so
it has roughly
uh
you know
closed n ones in every
uh row and every two rows have just one
intersection
and that's how it looks
the finite projective plane but it's not
clear that anything
would have taken me a long time to draw
an infinite matrix yeah yeah finite
projective plane and has to have some
particular size but
it's not really important in fact
what i'm going to say so we can call it
p
what i'm going to say will be true for
any matrix which has
uh
a constant
times square root n so
an arbitrary constant times growth and
one's
a row
and
a constant
a number of common ones
uh for every thought
so something like this so what i'm going
to say is true for any such matrix p
what is the statement the statement is
that the rank that there is zero you
know
non-zero rank
of this matrix so what does it mean any
matrix that has the same zero non-zero
pattern of this guy
linearly
so
think about it it doesn't matter how
utilized you're over there is over some
in an arbitrary crazy fashion you make
these ones into big and small and
transcendental numbers whatever you like
you cannot make the rank
drop
so the number of ones is at least square
root
yeah at least
yeah
so that's in this in my mind where you
relate itself a part of projects of
maybe building rigid matrices what it
says is that if for example
uh you change entries right what is
rigidity about logisticity you are
allowed to change entries arbitrarily
right and you want to drop the rank
if you just change the
uh
no if you are not allowed to make the
zeros non-zeros but you are allowed to
make
the non-zeros into zeros it will stay
higher
so
how close are these zeros just sort of
being
randomly distributed
i mean they they definitely have some of
the ones rather so if you if you pick
yeah yeah yeah so if you picked uh
rooten uh ones in every row at random it
will have this property
so in this sense it's uh yeah
um
okay so
uh so it is not connections i'm not
telling you because i'm just trying to
give you lots of examples let me move to
things that are more related to the
heart of this uh conference
and i want to talk about tensoring can
actually talk about two things uh
related to tensor length
we can ask one yeah sure all the
problems that you uh uh suggest it's
hard to find exclusive examples of they
all seem to involve some kind of
like l infinity bound or some kind of
handing down i mean you you don't
measure things in a nicer bond well in
the uh i mentioned the
approximate length is is in uh
uh oh you mean that it's a it's an
infinity but then it doesn't matter you
could do l2
you could do the other you could use l2
and you could get similar
yeah but uh yeah what i what i in fact
you're writing that the the what makes
the problems hard is
that uh
you don't have control over the
magnitude
in this approximate
rank you did have because it's a
relatively nice norm but usually
changes are arbitrary and that's what
makes the problem hard but that's
that's what makes it applicable too yeah
so i want to talk about uh
tensoring
and motivated but of course you know
tensorrank doesn't need any motivation
you know some of you are working on
improving lower bands for a tensor rank
and it's it's well motivated in itself
but i want to give extra motivation some
new connections
and in particular connections to
algebraic complexity theory these are
you know proving low bounds for tens of
this part of how you buy complexity
projects but it turns out that uh
sometimes they give you more than you
think tenza went robot so
uh
so let me just uh to make sure we are on
the same page so here we have uh so
what's the tensor so it tends though
we have sets uh
x i of size n these are the sets of
coordinates of the tensor and this is
just a map
form the d-dimensional tensor
is just a
uh d-dimensional matrix like this full
of entries with that right that's a
tensor
uh rank one tenzo is uh
rank of t
one if
um
simply the tensor power of some vectors
and
the rank in general the rank of t
is a
minimum
r such that we can write t as
t1 plus
dr where all these guys have rank one
okay
so
that's the tensor rank
problem and we want to find explicit
tensors with high rank we know again
what do we know that mostly
for mostly we know that
the rank of
is what what's the lower bound for
random
it's not n
it's not end to the d
yeah okay four yeah so the best uh we
know is something like n
uh sorry say so it's n for the d ma not
the best winner yeah
and to the d minus one over d
that's the best we know
we don't really know the answer maybe it
cannot be more than n to the d minus one
that's a trivial upper bound of
uh
we don't quite know whether this is
needed or not we don't know asymptotics
here this is a very interesting question
combinatorial question
in itself but
anyway we cannot approach it at all in
by explicit
turns off
we
have bounds that it's very close to that
and for explicit matrices no no no no no
no i know yeah so we yeah
and yeah i know but uh what i want is
basically that you know the upper bounds
for for any d of all
okay equals three we know everything
yeah for uh
for energy the upper bound is also of
this type
and you know the concept so this i have
to find out from good uh of course what
i'm interested in is explicit and the
best we know is the trivial bound
just the end to the
d over two
how do you get a lower bound like this
where you flatten it right i mean you
just take
you take an n to the d over two by n to
the d over two matrix
which is identity
and then you make a tensor out of it
so flattening is the only way and i'll
get to flattening more in a second
flattening is the only way it seems that
we have the only tool or variety of flat
innings is the only tool we have to
prove uh explicit tensor and slow bounce
and that's a of course a big challenge
so does the constant matter for you in
this example no i in the explicit no in
the cons you know for what we are so
what's the open what's the most basic
open problem so that's what we know
and what we want
is
uh
if this is explicit
t with a rank of t
were bigger than this anything bigger
would be fine so for example for d
equals three
with twice that or ten times
the usual it's a usual question it seems
we would want bigger than that we want
uh yeah plus epsilon so let's say four
for d equals three i would like n to the
one plus epsilon but
if you give me a hundred n i'm sure
you'll need to generate some interesting
ideas
so both are sticking we're like two or
three yeah but uh two or three maybe
next year you can do i trust you but
it's current yeah no do i know yeah sure
yeah
so yeah so it seems to me that uh
when we go to
to the real problem it seems that it's
the same with circle
[Music]
flattening is like this so supposedly i
want to prove to you i i want to give
you an explicit tensor
for d equals four
and explicit tensor d equal four where
length of t
is uh is n squared
right this is just the same for it
i just take the n squared by n squared
identity matrix
right
and now i call the entries here i j
between one and then i call them here k
l
and i make a fourth sensor out of it
really
okay
okay so we will get to flattening in a
second i just want to tell you about
some of you may not know this result of
ram ras
um
yeah yeah exactly that's the point
because you can
you can put parentheses
here
that's the reason
uh
the results of ramraz
says that so proving tensor low bounce
is probably the easiest problem in
arithmetic complexity theory uh
so what are you putting you're proving
circuit lower bound on arithmetic on on
polynomials on homogeneous polynomials
and
you're proving them for the simplest
type of circuits that's non-trivial
what's the
circuit it's a depth three circuit
what's what's this decomposition
is the composition of is the sum of
product of linear forms right that's
what it means sum of rank 1 tends those
sum of products of linear form so it's a
very simple circuit you are proving low
bounds for
but what run showed is that this would
suffice to prove
permanent lower bounds for general
arithmetic formulas so if you can prove
so if you can prove 4 i guess d less
than log n
if you can prove
if you have any explicit tensor
well the rank of t is close to what you
expect
and to the let's say one minus little
one
times d
still weaker than the maximum but
this will imply
so there are other ways to prove
permanent low amount
permanent
has
no
policized
arithmetic formulas
of any depth
we are moving a lower bound for that
three and that implies a superpolynomial
lower bound for any
super constantly yeah any super constant
d
this is the dimension of the tensor
it's the time that it lives in yeah
okay so the rule of one is a function of
v
so it's it's like if we were d minus
square root of d yeah it would be good
yeah yeah the little one one is the
function
so it has to be asymptotic indeed yeah
thanks
i want to go back to the flattening what
do i have ten minutes okay
good um
five minutes for each topic
so there's some discussion time so it's
okay
uh
so like i said maybe i hope it's clear
what this flattening is uh
in fact let me give a name to the what i
just
erased there if i have i'll just
restrict myself now to four dimensional
tensors
four-dimensional sensor so it has this
so it's uh
uh
you know we just have the ijk
and i want to uh flatten it in two
different ways into a matrix and that's
again this is a trick that you know i
guess many of you guys you use all the
time to put lower bounds on tenfold so i
will say
40
1 2
3 4
when i take the first two coordinates
and put them in the walls of a matrix
and the other two is uh
so i make it like this i put
i j here and k l here
and i also look at the t of
two three
four one so i
i put here
j okay so in this
number and here i put l
one
okay so there are two ways of getting a
matrix from a tensor these are the two
ways i care about
okay and now let me define a new notion
of length for a tensor
you may you know just bear with me
because there is a reason for this
so here's the weird notion of frank i
don't know how twiddle
i i want to say that it's r
or is this an r if i can write
t
as t1
c1
2
plus tr but now i don't want this to
have rank one stanzas all i want is that
either let me put this in there
i either
uh
the rank
of ci for every i so for every i either
of the rank of ti when i flatten it this
way
is one
oh
the rank of
the i when i flatten it the other way
one
okay
the definition can you explain where the
parentheses go in the statement is it
for all i one of the things happens or
either one happens no no no for each one
a different one may happen
another way to write it you only take
those two and don't take one three two
three because that's all i need
i'll say i'll tell you for what
you can no no wait i i there's a
okay yeah you can take it's very
interesting to take other flatness but i
don't want to
but your question another way to write
this
is to say that
t
can be written as t prime plus t double
prime
and the
the rank
of t prime when i flatten it this way
is less than r and the rank of t double
prime
when i flatten it the other way
we're up to [ __ ] those two maybe
one
okay so some are allowed to flip this
way so i'm allowed to flip the other way
now why why on earth would i define this
so what's the problem first of all the
problem uh it's easy to see that the way
i defined it uh the this twiddle rank
cannot be bigger than n squared
right
cannot be bigger and i want a lower
bound i want an explicit trend though
maybe i should write it here
i would like an explicit 10 though
want an explicit
c which
has rank
uh twitter rank of t
is bigger than nine to the one point
and why do i want that
it turns out that this will prove low
bounce on the on the permanent
there's a theorem
that we proved with the
hobash
and
your die off
this thing
implies
that permanent
requires
so now they're
and we're moving without defining uh
it's uh precisely to the
non-communicative
setting where we can you know
talk about
compute arithmetic circuits competing
with non-commuting variables there is a
notion of the permanent with
non-commuting variables
requires exponential size
if you want to put this as open as a
commutative case it's an easier problem
than a communicative case and i i
highly recommend working on it first
because it's easier
to prove with robots for non-commutative
circuits
this very simple question about this the
flattening of
and just these two flattenings of rank
will uh of tensorbank will
give you an exponential logarithm so
that's a
challenge
and
okay questions about this
actually that's a good question so let
me tell you
what tensor i think you should prove it
for
so here's the tensor an explicit tensor
you can call it the identity tensor it's
a particular t
t naught
i j k l
is simply
one
if
i j
equal
and zero otherwise
in terms of the flattening of this
itself so here if you flatten it
one two three four
this gives you the identity
but it's also true if you flatten it the
other way
because you know
this means that jk is the same as
so
this is my candidate and actually
i believe that this lower bound holds
for this t naught
we have no idea this is related to the
sum of squares problem not the sum of
squares
on convex programming but the sum of
squares from
uh you know algebra
um
and so yeah
we don't know this we worked very hard
on this and
you know
there are classical problems related to
this that i'm not going to get into the
sum of squares and
let me finish with the one last question
so
i'm a little confused sorry
what are you missing for the proof i
don't know that uh this you remember
this is just the flattening of the
tensor itself what i'm asking is about
decomposing it to two tensors
which
you know you know a low bound here means
that no matter how you
cut it out to twos i write it as a sum
of two tensors at least one of them will
have high rank
this is the tensor itself if you don't
i have the equations for this notion of
rank being studied so in the usual rank
there's a big study
equation
no
no i think it's pretty complicated then
uh it's got this quantifier either or
you know
it's reducible it's very useful it's
still very interesting yeah
but this
so anyway
i think it's a very
very simple concrete question about
tensors which you think should be easy
it implies this something that we've
been after for a long time and cannot do
the non-commutative permanent low bound
and
yeah but anyway but there are various
partial results but i'm not going to
talk about them let me just tell you the
last
thing between this is the most connected
to this workshop so i want to get to it
it's about non-commutative rank
since we got to non-commutative so if i
you know if i draw this
matrix for you
what's the rank of this matrix these are
variables
two yeah the rank is two so the rank is
two
this is true if x y commute
i mean in what we call uh sorry
in the usual algebra of polynomials but
the same
matrix rank 3
if they don't commute
it belongs to the
this algebra where x y is different than
y x
okay so uh we can define uh rank effects
i'm just going to define a full rank uh
for matrices like this so what matrix is
this we've seen it in several talks is
the linear pencil right this matrix of
uh matrix whose entries are linear forms
and variables okay so i'm going to
consider only such matrices so my matrix
a
will be x one
d one plus x two
and each of one of these vi's is just a
constant matrix
okay
but i want to think of these uh
variables as non-commuting value so i'm
working in the ring
and the question
okay the definition is a matrix like
this
uh has full rank if it cannot be written
as a product of
you know narrower matrices over the ring
so
uh
over this this ring
right uh if so is called full
this is the formal name it's called full
uh
if and only if uh there don't there do
not exist matrices bc
with entries here
uh such that
um and and this is n by r
and this is r by n our less than n
such that a equals b c so you cannot
factor a
using
yeah matrix narrower matrices then it's
full it's sort of the analog following
okay so how i give you now a matrix a
how difficult it is to tell whether it's
full or not
give you what i mean just i just give
you the matrices vi
yeah it's without without loss of
generality you can have two parameters
the size of the matrix and number of
variables can differ but without loss of
generality is the same number
so it's a complexity problem i give you
something like this you want to know
uh
so it's so it's just given a is a full
and this turns out to be a really
interesting problem for several reasons
first of all this is turned out to be
the world's problem for the
uh
non-commutative through symmetric fields
i mean it's really it captures the
question of whether
an element in the localization of this
uh
algebra is a zero element or not it
turns out to
for those who for whom it means anything
but another way to think about it
is that it captures the polynomial
identity testing
when you work with non-commutative
polynomials but you allow division
allowing division in the non-commutative
setting is something extremely
complicated
so anyway so it's a it's a very natural
problem extending the kind of problems
we look at
uh
in uh you know in algebraic complexity
theory but the third reason which is uh
connected to invariant theory is that
if you consider when a matrix like this
is full
you realize that this property is
preserved if you
pre and post multiply all the matrices z
i's by a fixed matrix
right so so
d1 up to the end i mean this linear
pencil defined by them is full
even only if
you know
let's go i don't know
m z one
i don't change anything if i pre and
post multiply by non-singular by
non-singular
[Music]
so what does it mean it means that there
is an action here there is an action of
uh
dear then
of the ln on these tuples which we
talked about right but
this is not their joint action it's you
know you don't conjugate the matrices
you you look from the left and from the
right by different matrix another action
what are the invariants turns out that
the invariants would give you an
algorithm to do this
and the invariants were figured out by
both by dirksen
and i guess raymond
and also by
democrats
and uh the probe i guess
this corresponds to the quiver that
looks like this end times right
for those who like quivers
so
they figured it out for all quivers but
just for this what are the invariants
where the invariants here are obvious in
variance now you should think of these
as matrices of variables
the invariants are simply
determinants
of sums of
what do i use
um
bi tensor
vi
well the bis
are from all from some
so that we understand all invariants and
now the only question is well we know
this is an infinite set of invariants
because we are allowing all k
the question is what's the smallest
scale for which you know we know that
the finite set of invariants there so it
means you know
there's a maximum k for which
uh you need to go in order to
tell whether a matrix is full or not
what's the largest case so what's the
minimum
what's the degree of generating a
variance here
and if this number was polynomial like
it is for example for the joint section
right that's missile of proof gives you
an n squared upper bound on the degree
if this was polynomial then we could use
just we would have a randomized
algorithm for this word problem
the best upper bound on this k uh as far
as i know is due to direction is an
exponential in it so
is polynomial
i
i asked some of the experts and uh they
feel that this is uh yeah like shawfield
thinks that this should be polynomial
but for example you could have
polynomials so that the thing is
integral over it instead of it's here
yeah yeah so
no it's yeah it would be good enough
yeah yeah yeah i think it would be good
enough for this algorithm it would give
a polynomial time probabilistic
algorithm for pit for this
non-commutative
yeah yeah yeah absolutely yeah and i
think you are interested in the same
problem for different
absolutely i know
yeah so that's why i want to get to it
but let me stop so
thank you very much
[Applause]
yeah there were many questions in the
middle
[Music]
accumulation of questions
thank you
[Applause]
right